the london mother who's accusing police
they're racially profiling her family
after a 12 year old son kai
was dragged from the house during the
night and handcuffed all because his
toy gun was suspected of being the real
thing
mina ajipong talked us through a bit
more about what happened
about 12 midnight on that friday
and so i just crossed over into saturday
early hours of the morning
and we've been up sort of in the living
room
and you know kai went to open the door i
followed him
and we just was presented with you know
about four or five officers holding
rifles
and guns they had visors um
red beams you know sort of on our bodies
on our heads
um it just looked like something out of
a movie they
said like put your hands up you know
which i did um
all of us did i've got two other
daughters who were sitting on the stairs
kai
obviously was in front of me we were
just putting our hands up i was sort of
explaining to them i haven't got any
firearms i haven't got anything illegal
in the house um just you know
i didn't understand why it was there but
they was very very poised serious
had their guns straight ahead i just
said you have to come out the property
one by one
um my my son had no he had just joggers
on he had no top on
he had no um shoes on and they just
arrested him immediately
and cuffs behind his back
dozens of officers descended on the
family's home with sniffer dogs and
found 12 year old kai in his
plastic pellet toy gun now the raid came
about
after a passerby alerted to police
saying that they saw what they
thought through the living room window
was a black male holding a firearm on
the sofa but of course as it turns out
it wasn't the case now kai's mother says
the metropolitan police therefore
racially profiled her family
which she says has never been in trouble
over the law or police before
london police chiefs on their side of it
say there's been no misconduct and that
the boy was let go as soon as it was
clear the toy gun
was not a real firearm the case has been
referred to the independent
office for police conduct meantime as
well kai's mother described the effect
it's all had on her family
traumatized disbelief shock
i was angry as well once once the guns
had gone away then that feeling of
you know why have you done this we've
done nothing wrong
it was just in our own home on a friday
evening
in a roundabout way they just sort of
said we follow up you know
firearms reports take them seriously we
have to follow them up
which i'm in agreement with we just
disagree on how they follow it up
but mainly they were saying you know
because of the gun related gang-related
crime in the area
the fact that kai was a male there was a
mention of him being a black male
obviously you know in the report
all of those things um you know they
take very seriously
and um you know didn't quite explain why
such
excessive force but they just said you
know they was just doing their job
basically
i'm more than aware of of how
disproportionate young black men
are stopped and searched by the police
particularly in my area
and they're almost targeted and then you
know i didn't make my complaint straight
away i waited to speak to the
chief um the superintendent and he
started talking about operation trident
he started talking about
um you know gang-related crime and
making those associations
um and that he read me out the report
that was made
by the passerby and there was very
little evidence there at all
but there was the fact that it was a
black male
and i think that that did have something
to do with it as a mother i can speak
probably for a lot of mothers who have
young boys
very very fearful of of young boys in
today's society but certainly young
black boys
i am more more fearful of him growing up
he's not even 13 yet
he's 12. so i'm so scared when he gets
to 15
16 how the police are going to perceive
him how they're going to treat him
because obviously he's seen as a big big
threat
right now and they came to the door
clearly a 12 year old child
immediately arrested him um on the
possession of firearms that was the
suspicion
so i'm terrified